good morning guys I'll get to the point
right away
I'm retiring it's the end of the road or
field for Tom Brady for good and his
ex-wife Giselle Bundchen is reacting she
is the goat yup it's official again the
45 year old quarterback shared a short
video revealing his football career has
come to a definite end and he couldn't
help but get emotional I know the
process uh was a pretty big deal last
time so when I woke up this morning I
figured I just pressed record and let
you guys know first so I won't be
long-winded uh really thank you guys so
much to every single one of you
for supporting me my family
my friends my teammates
my competitors
I could go on forever there's too many
thank you guys for allowing me to live
my absolute dream
I wouldn't change
thing
love you all and Gisele who divorced Tom
in October hit up the comments with a
supportive message quote wishing you
only wonderful things in this new
chapter of your life I feel like I'm so
driven to succeed in football and that's
taken me away from
other important priorities which are my
kids my wife and she's really held it
down for our family and I'm just super
grateful that you know she really
committed so much of her time the last
you know 14 years to make sure
everything was so stable at home so I
could go live my dream of course Tom
spent 20 Seasons as the QB for the New
England Patriots before making the jump
over to the Tampa Bay Buccaneers he
announced his retirement from the NFL
last February only to unretire less than
two months later did you just need a
vacation is that what brought you back
you took a little time off and you sent
him back there was a little more than
that it's not something you just can
decide I needed time and I just figured
I'm gonna go at it again and see what we
can accomplish but the year had its
share of fumbles including the decision
to end his 13-year marriage I think
there's a lot of Professionals in life
that go through things that they deal
with at work and they deal with at home
and obviously the good news is things
it's a very amicable situation
so what's Tom going to do next well it
seems he's got a bit of an acting bug
after making his big screen debut in 80
for Brady the Super Bowl is no place for
four old women this could be Tom's last
one he's almost 40. let's go oh my God
are you gonna act again because let's
see I don't know make some offers let's
see what we could do all right football
movies the booth what's next
we're all trying to figure it out so
just taking it day by day and my friend
says the future happens a day at a time
so that's what life's all about so I'm
enjoying tonight is really a magical
night for me and a lot of the people who
put a lot of hard work into this so love
being here supporting them and um you
know maybe there's a 80 for Brady sequel
coming out look he's
[Music]